-You look fantastic.
-Let me take this off.
-Would you like me to hold
your jacket?
-Sure, thank you, Jimmy.
That's very nice of you.
-Absolutely.
Welcome back to our show,
Aubrey.
I've missed you.
I haven't seen you in a while.
-I know, it has been too long.
-You've been busy, busy, busy.
-I know.
-You just got back from Italy.
-That's right.
-You're filming the new season
of "White Lotus."
-That's right, "White Lotus."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah!
Whoo! I cannot wait for this.
It's very secretive, obviously.
-Yes.
-But I'm a big fan
of the first one.
And we all love Mike White
and Jennifer Coolidge.
And so here's the description
of your character.
-Yeah.
-Hopefully, no spoilers.
You ready?
-Okay.
-A woman on vacation with
her husband and his friends.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for that.
No spoilers.
-Yes.
-Wow.
-I am playing against type.
-Wow. [ Laughs ] Yeah.
That's amazing.
-Big time.
-Yeah, you're always typecast.
You're always the woman
who's not on vacation.
-Exactly.
I would never do that.
-You would never go on vacation
with your husband
and his friends?
-Nuh-uh. No.
-Uh-uh.
-No, no, no.
-How did you end up
working on this?
-Mike and I -- actually, we've
been friends for a long time.
So, we were trying to come up
with something else to do
together,
and then the pandemic happened.
And we ended up -- and then,
he just ended up, you know,
bringing me to the party.
-I can see you guys totally
working --
-It was crazy.
-Yeah.
I mean, you've been out there
for five months?
-Five months.
Yeah, that's a really long time.
-Yeah. Do you speak Italian?
-Si, parlo Italiano --
Parlo un po Italiano.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Grazie mille.
- Si. Yeah, but I was out there
for five months.
The show's epic.
There's all kinds of --
everyone kept getting COVID,
so we kept kind of, like --
you know?
And then before that, I was
shooting a movie in Italy.
Another -- a different thing
called "Spin Me Around,"
which is coming out this month,
that my husband directed.
So, I've really been in Italy
for like almost a year
if you, like,
put it all together.
-Let's talk about
"Emily the Criminal."
-Okay.
-You also produced it.
-I did.
-Yeah.
-That's why I wear
the big jacket.
-Yeah, exactly.
-'Cause every talk show,
I'm going to get a bigger
and bigger jacket
until it's on
the God damn floor.
-I'm ready to -- I'm ready to --
Yeah.
-I'm going to come out with
a big cigar in my mouth.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Remember movies?
-Yeah, you want to produce
some movies?
-Yeah, you want me to produce
your movie?
Give me $500,000 --
- Dollars.
-Dollars.
That's actually not enough.
-No.
What is "Emily the Criminal"
about?
-"Emily the Criminal" is about
a woman from New Jersey,
who is in L.A.,
and she is basically saddled
with thousands of dollars
of student loans and debt,
which I think we can all relate
to, or at least a lot of us.
-Sadly, yes.
-Yeah, right?
And so, she's kind of drowning
in debt.
She has a criminal record.
You know, she did some stuff.
You know?
Sometimes you do some stuff.
And -- but she can't get a job.
-[ Laughs ]
-And she's -- she basically is
tipped off to do this kind of
illegal crime thing.
Like a scam kind of thing.
And it's a petty crime,
but it's still illegal.
And she finds out she's kind of
good at it.
And so, she kind of, you know,
goes down that path and becomes,
you know, the criminal.
-You got to do
some action scenes which..
-I did.
-I like seeing Aubrey Plaza
doing action.
-Yeah, thank you very much.
-And I was -- I was wondering.
I said, "Would you every do more
action things?
You go, "That's funny you asked,
James.
Because I'm on the cover of
'Movie Maker Magazine.'"
-I am.
-Which -- look at this.
-There I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right. "Movie Maker."
-You're on the cover of
"Movie Maker" magazine.
-Yeah, I -- they asked me to be
on the cover of "Vogue,"
but I said, no, I'm doing
"Movie Maker."
-That's right.
You tell them what's up.
-So --
-This is the one. "Movie Maker."
-So, take that.
-That's exactly what you want
to be on.
But then, your friend, is it --
-Yeah, so, my friend,
Edgar Wright, actually saw that
and texted me
and said, "Oh, my God,
You're the new Lara Croft?
You're the new 'Tomb Raider?'"
That's the character in --
and I was like, "No, Edgar.
That's my movie,
'Emily the Criminal.'"
And he genuinely thought I was
cast as the new "Tomb Raider."
-He thought
that was a gun holster.
That's not a gun,
that's just a purse.
-That's a purse, yeah.
And then -- exactly.
Exactly.
-But I can see it.
I can see this happening.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. I know.
-I can actually see
this happening.
-Right? I know.
-Yes.
-It's funny because I didn't
actually -- and then,
I looked it up and I was like,
they are actually --
they are casting
this role right now.
And I was like,
"Well, there you go.
The new 'Tomb Raider.'
Whatever."
-There you go.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Right?
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Aubrey Plaza
in "Emily the Criminal."
Take a look at this.
-We just need to go back to
the office for just a second.
-Why? What's wrong?
-Nothing. We forgot one thing.
It's just -- it's my fault.
-You can't tell me what it is?
-It's not big deal, you know?
So, just -- can you turn off
the engine, please?
Turn off the engine.
-Hey, hey. No!
[ Horn honks, woman screams ]
[ Man grunts ]
-[ Hyperventilating ]
[ Engine revs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Aubrey Plaza.
"Emily the Criminal"
is in theaters this Friday.